how's the Cobra is my spear it's a sunny
afternoon walk that a time to pee anyway
I guess you could call this a hacked
game it came out as a parody like a fake
game and you see my signal yes that's
important in this game that you see my
team does it's a game where you pee on
the wheat now literally I arrived three
words I'm practically a rapper the audio
is probably checked but hey what are you
gonna do on April 1st 2008 pinky
promoted a Wii game called super peepee
brothers so you don't keep your mouth
that's five coming believe you for you
from your date novel and this is
probably the best idea of a game that I
ever heard some I I I'm currently not
drunk at all
oh there we go Oh anybody into a pig
come on
no hands no hands yeah come on baby
nothing yes we brethren it's level two
so now we're a little drunker okay let's
step it up
oh god I'm shaking I mean this is
probably the best game ever
I know I say that a lot a still better
story than minecraft and so better
gameplay than call of duty
let's be honest nothing can beat this
really how having the time about that we
hit who this game must be great for
girls in Plato like might beer belly by
the way other sin ridin foot there poor
guy
oh you liked it
Hey what are you doing thank God every
year ah damn it
Oh No do I start over
let's try thing for my face maybe that's
better
oh it's not better to be from the face
remember this trip oh god I'm really be
physics amazing okay I our radio is
broken psychic Joseph lines in my
neighbor just look back nothing to see
here just me being on my way you really
I mean I played some shitty games this
one probably wins perfect wool on the P
makes out the P master Oh guys 0.5%
alcohol okay I'm starting to feel like
just don't want to get it this is
practically how you Pedro this is Kiki
drugged simulator amazing and you
thought simulator games have gone too
far
no past oh god this is getting really
hard now that's what she said get it
that actually made sense in this game no
no no goddamn it my urine has a mind of
its own stop it what is this my urine is
a last hope if my turn is attacking me
oh well what are you gonna do okay the
real question is can I pee city
oh my god and king
yeah amazing
all right brother
that was speed simulator I guess taste
hope you enjoyed watching this is really
[ __ ] up tiny little game I'm sorry it
was a short video but it was a [ __ ] to
set up so what are you gonna do thank
you for liking of this video bros and
thank you for hanging out with me today
it's been great pissing with ya stay
awesome bros bro